Je sais que tu es triste quoi que tu penses
t'aider J'ai la responsabilité en
tant qu'ami de te dire que ce n'est
pas un plan Je t'envoie chez mon
père sur l'île c'est beau
en hiver sérieusement comme quoi quoi  je
fais ici tu t'assois juste là et
tu regardes l'eau et tu penses
à ta vie hé je suis un ami irlandais
Jack
donc tu es sur une île il est 3h00 du
matin et tu bois tout seul
ce qui est  Je viens de sortir d'une
relation de sept ans
Je dirais quelque chose mais c'est super
sûr parce que tu es lesbienne si tu
étais différemment incliné cette nuit
pourrait aller d'une manière très très différente Je
dis juste qui tu sais qu'elle est  toi
elle est là elle ne peut pas savoir ça
je cours tu dors non tu dois
avoir longtemps et maintenant tu es comme un
double coup dur tu veux que j'invente une
histoire pour qu'elle ne sache pas que moi
ça dit qu'elle est ta  soeur, je suis sa meilleure
amie et c'est bizarre de donner quelque chose pour
ma soeur, je '  d aimez-vous j'ai l'air d'être
un gars sympa